every country has a central bank
issuing currency managing monetary
policy and making sure that the banking
system is well oiled and functioning
smoothly
with the creation of the euro european
leaders decided that the currency needed
its very own central bank
headquartered in frankfurt it has a
president currently it's italian mario
draghi
the president is part of an executive
board which oversees day-to-day business
it comprised of former national bank
governors and high-level banking
executives chosen by the european
council
the ecb dwarfs all other banks in europe
overseeing the monetary affairs of the
19 countries of the eurozone
it's also a supranational institution
independent of member state control
but accountable to the public its main
role is to maintain price stability
in the eurozone it has to keep the rate
of inflation
close to or below 2 it is also
exclusively in charge of issuing euros
and setting monetary policy for the euro
zone
at the height of the financial crisis in
2008
the ecb had to navigate through a few
tough years
bailing out eurozone countries in
economic downturn
after the crisis relented a fail-safe
against further crises was set up
the banking union moved europe away from
bailing out banks
to bailing them in and the ecb's role in
all of this
to control europe's banks under the
single supervisory mechanism